follow me
okay for people joining this live stream
we are talking about the future of
arrays in wolfram language
and
rob is going to show us some things
okay
so right so is that all visible and good
and you know yep excellent great okay so
so we've had we've had numbers of
discussions and
and there's sort of been two
two thrusts of of of what we've done and
one i sort of
um have worked you know thinking of of
your idea that you talked about
rectangular stata so i sort of came from
a rectangular point of view
and i think leonoid has worked from a
more hierarchical
flattening point of view and they both
sort of come to the same point um
this concept of tabular data so
um i've also some of what i've developed
i'm going to show you stuff and if you
get
tired of this you can tell me to move on
but but there's also some stuff that i
think would just be useful
utilities
for particular rectangular data outside
of the the the general idea of you know
an array container or something
so okay rectangularist data is data
that's accessible with part you say
there
right right
um and i've listed some advantages here
um
so
seeing the big advantages are
parts or bits of the data
are easily changed and accessed
um
and the disadvantage is if you take
you know if you take if you filter it or
select you know some based on parts
you know outside of part
you sort of break you can break the
rectangularity so and and often and this
doesn't really
this model doesn't work very well for
hierarchical data as well
so
you know unless you have a data
container inside a data container and
then that gets
i think lionel has some nicer solutions
for that type of thing
okay so once something lifting is not
special here missing is just some part
that might be treated differently by
functions that operate on the data on
the content of the data but missing is
still present as a part correct scene
missing is still present at the park
that's that's that's that's that's an
important fundamental idea okay all
right
yeah that's that's key and in fact so
this first simple example i've taken has
a missing in it
to sort of you know try to you know try
to deal with that to make sure we're
dealing with that in some way and of
course i've i've just got really simple
examples here to illustrate the
principles
not so much the potential okay so here's
a this is a rectangular data called r
data one
and a command i put together is a
generalization of dimensions that also
tells you about about associations right
it tells you it tells you about
associations and i wrapped association
keys in something called key list
apparently so it's easy to see and also
you'll see there's a there's another
reason uh why later okay i got this idea
this is an interesting okay yeah and and
this actually is implemented through an
additional thing i added to this more
recently is the idea of
you may want to name levels
indeed we've talked about that that's an
important and so this data dimension you
specify the levels um and it gives them
names every instead of returning a list
it returns an association with the
levels
but wait a minute in the actual data
thing
right now we have we do not have a way
of naming i mean for example for data
set it would be lovely to be able to
name levels well that's yes that's
that's coming stephen that's coming
that's part of the that's part of the
idea of the the container design okay
so good so so i figured we'd get through
this okay so this is this is data that's
that i would it's not rectangular but
it's rectangular-ish
and so if you just do the data
dimensions on this by itself it just
gives you two
okay but what i've done is i've set up a
version of data dimensions now this is
toggled by a thing and what it does is
okay do i merge so the reason this is
not rectangular is it has different keys
at this
this
this alpha level okay so a b c
a b c instead of d
and so it's not rectangular but if we
say okay let's merge keys and consider
the whole set of keys possible that that
appear on any given level and it's it's
exactly the orders this is with key yoon
merge join and join across so it's
they're they're precedents for this and
now we actually get rectangular
representation right but so conceptually
you've got a missing in the places where
it wasn't where there was a
non-rectangular hole previously
precisely precisely
um and yep so
so so that's so the container if it if
it partified if it part extracted into
the hole it would see a missing
yes yes
um and that's that's the concept okay so
so
so something we're going to need to work
with this data in any efficient way is
conversion to
to what i call list arrays which are
just just lists okay and this is this is
sort of like this is like values on
steroids basically okay
it goes and removes all the keys so we
we can remove the keys
we get this of course we save huge
amounts of memory
um and this is this is the key the key
thing we can do is we can restore the
keys
yeah i got it i mean this is the idea of
the data container right so i mean
the inner
dense
data object
which probably in in some world of the
future could also be in a sparse data
object
yes i think right well that's yes that's
that's a that's another representation
i'm going to get to here so yeah so so
this is
so so so i've written a whole bunch of
utilities that work with this that will
make you know putting together this data
container much easier you can also for
example you want to change keys you can
change keys by putting in a different
data dimensions with different keys
um
and
so here here's the case where it was not
so rectangular
and
so we
we
we end up with some missings here yep
um as you would expect um
um but you can also restore the keys
fully and it instead of putting the
missing it just association levels it
just leaves them out which makes sense
okay
so but by the way the only thing i would
comment about that round tripping is um
uh the question of the order
of the association elements
you know when you have
i mean i don't know whether it's
preserving that in the round trip
well it it it it changes it because
otherwise we have to save the the the
order
so it doesn't preserve it it does not
preserve it no
no it it it goes back to that merge keys
order um which i think is a reasonable
thing to do
um what happens if you what happens if
you have an explicit missing in the
association is that treated differently
yes
yes i i think that you should have a
different uh
key in the missing to represent this
kind of uh
i mean
it is it's a missing key absent
but isn't that the same thing as oh key
absent is different from from the case
where you have extracted where you've
used lookup for example on an
association and you get and you ask for
something that isn't there what do you
get in that case
that's that's what you get it's missing
key absent
when it's okay i'm just
no i think it might be useful to have a
different
key in the missing
to represent this form of implicit key
absent
maybe not maybe not i don't know i you
get what i'm saying though yeah i get
what you're saying i think that's a
that's a that's a detail i mean there's
there's lots of details yeah so that's
that's the detail so i'm just i'm
putting that okay let's go that's it's
good to get details
okay so here's here's here's a another
so so this is the idea of conversion to
a to a list array which is which is
really useful but there's also another
another way and and you know a lot of
a lot of our backends are going to use
this this idea of tabular data
such as you know
query language stuff um
arrow data
which i'll be showing an example of
later and so having a conversion to
tabular data is also useful and this is
actually in some ways a little it's it's
it's not as efficient as convergent list
data but it's also a bit more general
too so what is tabular data okay by
tabular data that's that's why i've
shown a bunch of tables here the idea is
it's it's got it's it's basically the
data flattened to 2d
okay and so we take the we take the
the last dimension
here
okay
and then these first these appending
rows these are actually the dimensional
you know listing what the dimension name
actually is so here the index is one
here the dimension you know this is the
alpha key this is the a key
wait a minute so why are there so the
bottom level
is
across the columns of this thing right
yes but all
other levels are just being put as the
prefix elements for each row
right
right okay i mean it's kind of a
hackasaurus but but that i mean well it
is a hack a source but it's quite you
know it's quite it's it's fairly
complicated with a lot of other things
and it's compatible with a lot of other
things and it's somewhat compatible with
what i think linwood is going to talk
about as well
um so we can also do it to tabular
columns the reason to do two columns
this is just an efficiency hack because
we know that these types are all the
same so we could store these in a packed
array or we could store this as a
string list if we had such a thing
um
what's the
what types are all the same
the types across these so this is just a
so each row is the same it's row is the
same so we
so we just i see i see so this is a
question of the fact that we because of
our data structures
being uh row first so to speak we can
um yeah we we can't
the the fact that a column is all of the
same data type doesn't help us as such
in the way that our internal practice
exactly and that's how things like this
arrow package for example and i think a
lot of you know sql databases work you
know on having the same type in a in a
column and then the row covers all of
the things
okay and then we can you know this is
just a transpose i said and it works
with this not quite rectangular data as
well
so here we just have the three
dimensions and then we have
you know these these data and this is
these are actually all data dimensions
in this case
but this case i purposely set up is you
may want to consider the data as
different types right you may want to
just consider this is a this is a
database of two by two matrices
and so you can do that
by specifying the dimension right you
can do that as well okay but hold on
hold on hold on hold on as soon as you
have a missing you're gonna blow out
unless you have some hack for storing
missing unless we have do we have a way
of packing this things yes well that's
that's one of the things that's one of
the things i'm working so so this aero
package um
has a way of packing missings very
efficiently um which will need to
integrate better and i've also set up
i've also set up a way we can develop
our own back-ends different backseats
and almost you know and there are
different ways of of packing missings
but yes the a key thing is being able to
pack missings because otherwise we lose
any efficiency in storage right cool
okay so that's
that's that's that's that's one of the
things i've thought about you know what
they spent a lot of time thinking about
when when doing all this and we can also
do conversion from the tabular data back
um
so we could have you know what
so so for example i can take you know
the tabular data of this
um
it's the same from now i can take you
know parts which are not necessarily
contiguous so this is not the same as
part of the rectangular thing
okay but i can still construct you know
reconstruct
that part of the rectangular expression
that's left
okay i mean in other words with pure
part extraction with lists and spans you
are guaranteed to go from a tabular
object to a tabular object
right
as opposed to running select or
something which could give you all kinds
of random guns well no this did this
could be this this case that i'm showing
here could be like a select
well in one dimension it could be but
not in two minutes yeah right
right well i'm getting to an idea of how
we can do
do select that that that i think leonoid
has a you know a more dimensional
solution for but but we'll get so
um yeah so we we can convert to the
tabular i have a point of language here
yes
leonid is leonid not leonoid isn't he
sorry
thank you
well it was kind of interesting to hear
a different version of my name
okay
it's sorry okay
it's all right it's all right it's a lot
more functional language i think when
denoid
yeah yeah
right
um okay go on yeah yeah okay so so
that's the that's the okay so now here's
here's the
uh which
which uh is is the idea of selection
from tabular data
okay so here i've set up a data
dimensions and i've given these i've
purposely given these these dimensions
these levels names okay and you can
actually see where the names appear
so now
i've i've set up a functional filter and
i can just use
you know like like
a function just like select so this is
like select but i'm now
referring to
you know columns in this tabular data
okay so it's kind of almost like an
array select
yeah it's like it it's it's like an
array select but it's it's you know on
the knowing you've flattened the data to
this two-dimensional form and so this is
a part
okay because it's the same part beta
right
so it would be all comma beta
um and then you can reconstruct the data
but you could also do
you know you could say do
um
you could filter by here i filtered by
the
you know the determinants so i'm
considering these two by two matrices so
which elements have a negative determine
okay so sorry just as a quick question
so
are are you actually constructing the
association there passing the function
or are you taking apart the function and
finding all the slots or something in
this in this in this case uh i've got
it's i actually called it naive filter
rose naive and it constructs the
association christopher that's a really
good question okay but that's
it's it's it's more of a proof of
concept than than actual doing and i
think it could be done you know even on
expression type data it could be done
you know much more efficiently than this
this is just a
this is sort of exploration
i think that i mean as we move towards
like more different backends like arrow
like
the the the actual way in which data is
stored is the disassociation right so
i'll be showing that with arrow in just
a moment okay so
this function itself is is naive
but the actual
link to arrow is not naive and it
actually works efficiently
okay but hold on let me just understand
what this is so
hash so greek
is essentially a level designator yeah
see that's this that that's a level
designation with this is column so
that's like a part
well it's a part in in your flattened
tabulated thing it's a part but
conceptually if this was a data set it
would be a level designator
oh it's actually uh steven i think it's
actually extracting a certain specific
key
uh because you know uh i'll have
examples of that as well but the idea is
if you have a
keyed layer of data basically an
association
then
when you do part extraction you can just
take
one like the key alphabet gamma
but in this flattened approach this part
extraction
translates into select
because the keys themselves yeah
they become data that's an essential
idea right that's then that's what i'm
trying to show so you can you can select
not only by part but you could you could
have an and and i could select on both
of these criterions for example with
this function
and also that with the arrow case
so
so
the thing is the thing is i put this
note here note how irritated need to put
in the data dimensions to expand back
okay and that's that's that's a key
thing data containers going to provide
for us it's going to store these
dimensional names and the data
dimensions and everything all in one
place
and then all these operations should be
much more automatic
okay
so so now i'm sort of so these are what
i've shown
here are just sort of utilities that may
be useful
you know on their own to some extent but
but the the real thing i put together is
this data container
okay so so the idea is that
actually i just note that edmund on the
live stream is commenting that um
the resource function table set
he suggests is
a way of not having to construct
is a mechanism for not having to
construct the explicit association
something to look at
okay i'll take a look at that
um i wasn't even aware of that so
but
um that's why it's useful to have yes
that's why exactly
okay um keep going
okay so so so the idea is we're going to
have a data container and it's going to
contain an expression and this could be
this could say be a file which you might
want to read from i'm working with
actual you know sets of lists and
associations in my examples here but it
could be a you know file name or some
other expression
um
and then the idea is it's gonna it's
gonna try and coerce it into some
storage type that you've specified and
we'll probably ultimately have some kind
of automatic storage type that it'll
automatically pick the best thing but at
this stage
you know we don't we don't have enough
to put together an automatic yet okay so
i've i've this this column list is
something i developed in c
um so this can work directly with c
functions um for some efficiency or it
can actually work with you know a
mathematical level code as well so
so in this this has various properties
which will do
you know the these properties are sort
of like data structure like properties
but ultimately there will be commands
which will get these things out so so
realize these properties you see are not
the final design they're just
experimenting hold on hold on the basic
point is data container can be thought
of as a constructor which eats
things like data sets files other things
potentially databases one day
um
and
then the second argument specifies or
some version of the second argument
specifies
uh what's the internal form that will be
used i mean it's kind of analogous to
what
uh
it's
would be analogous to what dataset is
doing except that here there's a single
api that deals with this that doesn't
care what the actual internal where the
external functions being used in our
language don't care about what the
internal storage mechanism right right
exactly that's that's that's that's
that's the fundamental idea
right okay so
i'm going to talk about some of the sort
of api one is normal right so normal
should produce
not obvious normal should not produce
the data set
right it may yeah so so whether it's a
data set or you know here i gave it a
list of associations and stuff and
whether that's a data set um well the
question is when it comes back if you
feed in a data set or you feed in a file
yeah if you say data container of a file
when you say normal of that thing you
don't want to get the file back you want
to get back
some
normal yes yes yes exactly what i'm
asking is to me it seems like you
probably want to get back
by default a data set you can call
normal again if you want to turn that
data set into lists of associations this
is a detail that's not working that's
that's a detail that can certainly
that's that's easy enough to do
um
okay and then another another thing is
is particularly this is something
particularly relevant to rectangular
state is part should work as well
okay and i've i've unfortunately got
some bug in my code so parts not giving
exactly the same part but it should give
exactly the same as the original
expression
when you know applied to part as well
okay i understand so this data container
like data set
which also accepts parts
and
is data set is data container going to
accept queries like dataset does
well that's that's what we that's what
we ultimately want to do and and you
know we need to figure out how to bridge
make that make that bridge and i think
leonoid's ideas will go a ways to doing
that
um
but wait a second if you have a data set
in your own pattern data set you get
another data set back
so in in a way we could do the same
thing and make part kind of lazy
if it's on a file or something like that
and only only you do normal you you'd
extract yeah but here here's here's
here's your point so so this was a
single part so this is a single element
that i showed here here is
if it has dimensionality left it returns
another data container
but doesn't data set return a data set
even if it is a singleton i believe it
does no no i don't think so okay
okay
i don't i don't think that would be the
right thing to do right and your your
sub value of data dimensions is just a
hack for right now in the future exactly
yeah a lot of these things are just
hacks for right now just okay okay let's
keep going
it takes you know it takes it takes me
three minutes to write data mentions as
a string thing and it you know
put that in dimensions would take three
hours so yeah um yeah so we can also do
transpose again this is a hack okay i
get it it's a transpose thing but it
actually what it what this does is it
actually transposes the the dimensions
and it's actually transposed just no see
this is this is for the rectangular data
it transforms the wrapper and so it's
implicitly transformed it's only when
you do normal that actually implements
the actual
good and
so and the same applies for flattened
too so these are things that are very
rectangular oriented but they're they're
quite useful here
um
so flattening is just changing the index
translation
yes exactly and it's very much like you
remember we have that that weird way you
can specify levels in flatten that we
put together you know it's exactly that
and that's what jose uses in quantity
array
uh something very similar to that and
this it's this thing it's a property you
can look up called flattening
um
and so notice these data dimensions i've
put in you know a key list with multiple
things so that keeps it compact but that
actually represents so key list
of just a list is just those keys but
with the you know several arguments it
represents an outer product which are
which are these things
these are the terms in the outer product
i think we need to look at that some
more yeah i don't know what you're
saying but but i mean what you're saying
is
yeah i'm not sure that's quite the right
way to do it i mean that you're saying
for a rectangular-ish thing it's all out
of products
because that's what a rectangle that's
what rectangular issues
is that it's not a product of keys
right right
so
um you know and
you know so i've set up i've set up this
filter then i'm going to show with the
arrow link and that's kind of like that
naive filter i have above and then
you know we need to think we need to
think
so so so fundamental thing
is what so i've set up the framework for
for the data
data container but a lot of the api is
not filled in yet
so let's so so the the whole a whole big
thing about the the
data containers i set it up is i've i
wrote that column list thing in c so it
can work through c functions but it also
worked through something
defined completely you know in the
wolfram language
okay and it's got a it's got a
registration system so
they've actually included this in the
latest version of the aerolink package
um
and
um so all i did need to do is do needs
arrow
who's working on the arrow oh that's uh
pyotr and raphael i think the the image
processing team yeah okay
um
and and it's quite a nice it's quite a
nice packet um
it's not done yet but it's but it's
quite nice and very efficient um and so
basically the storage the the
registration as i say a register a
storage method and this is not something
users are going to use this is what our
developers will ultimately be able to
use and then there's a bunch of
functions for different api type
functions that'll need to know how to do
um so it's quite general that's that's
that's what i said general enough to
include also an sql database
i believe so yes um especially if i
moved away i i actually hooked up
as one example christopher's sqlite
compiler database connection
and that's one of the things doing that
made me realize we really need to think
in sort of this a little bit more in
this tabular model than the rectangular
model for a lot of things um
but yes that and that connection wasn't
very nice at this stage but it but it
but the concept does work
by the way what is happening to the
sqlite
concept of user-created and
user-writable databases
is that the thing i mean that wasn't
part of the ece meeting
um
christopher is there a is there a plan
for that well i'm not i think leonid is
working on some things so maybe he
should answer but i mean
the only things i did is i made like
this demo for for
linking desk you like with the compiler
which
like i made in like an afternoon or
something
so i mean it wouldn't be hard i mean
honestly the the dusty light api is
pretty small and pretty simple so it
really wouldn't be hard to make like at
least a packlet that lets you do that
kind of thing
can we make sure if nothing else that's
covered it's added as a project to the
global project list
can i just mention that um i've also
built the um
a version of sqlitelink based on
librarylink that is uh already being
used at least in testing for entity uh
that's right okay and uh in fact there
was a there was a discussion
uh to
have uh maybe
a more extended discussion about sqlite
uh
shortly after the release of 13.1 of
differently involving youtube okay fine
terrific okay just
to add is that the the other database
project the one that's compatible also
with the big server based ones
actually has writing and created
databases it's just i mean if we have a
design length we design a language for
writing to databases it will be pretty
quick to hook that up as well because
internally we do write to databases all
the time so for for testing and so on
it's just not exposed to the top level
okay okay so if we have that if we have
a mutable version i mean data container
is not in any way mutable is that true
rob
um well we we can we can decide whether
it's mutable or not i mean it's it's
implemented
just like the data structures um so so
yes there could be a mutable version
interesting very interesting
good i'm sorry just from project
management point of view can we make
sure that the sqlite database is on the
global project list i believe that it is
but could aubry could you please check
that
yes
okay all right on mode yeah okay so we
load the arrow link code this that
actually includes this registration
command so so this just works and then
we can set up you know i've set up a
simple data which
works with
the arrow types um
and i've given you know names and then
you know we can do the the normal is
exactly like the original except it's
converted everything to floating point
um not surprisingly because
well well i think i think what we'll be
able to do and i i haven't read the i
think piotr and raphael might be able to
is you can define your own type for
arrow and so i believe we could have an
expression
you know expression list type for
example i mean so arrow is basically
dealing with floating point data is that
correct
well and boolean integer
um so why did that 16 come back as a 16
point as opposed to a 16.
oh because it's i mean each column so i
specified the column types it's actually
a you know i suppose i call them types
okay and it needs to know what the
column types are and i think i think
okay
yes it could be it could be integers but
since this had things like square root
of two in this column i wanted i i get
it
so that's so there's a type conversion
that happened
that
i don't know i mean do what what do we
have okay if you've got a compiler type
which is what those are right real 32 is
the pilot type right and i just want to
take a thing like square root of two the
symbolic expression and i want to cast
it into that compiler type
we have a function a cost function which
you could use at top level correct
we could but there's risks of having
that just evaluate because then it
becomes much harder to write compiled
code
okay but how do we get go ahead so i
think we talked about having a top-level
version of cast i think the end
conclusion was that we shouldn't because
basically there are lots of things that
it really can't do
um like it's certainly you know you
can't you can't get all the casts that
the compiler does you certainly can't
get those in the top level maybe you get
a subset of them but most of the useful
subsets you can already get using
functions like n
and and of course you know if you cast
from a real 64 to real 32 that's a
meaningful thing in the compiler i don't
think it's really a meaningful thing in
the top level
um well
yeah so the problem i mean i'll add to
the problem it you know at top level is
that we don't you know so so so our our
atomic types
you know for expression are integer
machine real you know big real
so on and so forth so we we only have
one concept of machine reel
okay but but i guess my question is for
debugging purposes even the cost from
real 64 to real 32
giving a faithful cast that you could
see at the top level that includes
losing bits and so on seems like a
useful thing to have yeah well this we
do it's just not very convenient
numeric
array
of okay fine i i suggest that we have
some utility function that does these
things
yeah
um fine that's yeah so okay um
yeah it would be nice to have a utility
function um and i'm not sure what it
should do but it'll still it'll still
convert it back into a machine number
yeah
but yeah it'll just be with chopping off
bits and things like that yeah it'll
chop off the right number of bits
okay i think that's that's that's a
useful utility i'm not sure what it
should be called but
okay fine i mean we've got similar
things for string encoding for you know
doing various kinds of
sort of machine like string encoding
kinds of things okay let's keep going
yeah okay so so this this again this
this so now i've now i've specified you
know the data i specified their type as
this arrow table type
and
i've also put in
i allow a third argument where you can
specify sort of details of what the
conversion might be or you know details
of the data so here i've include
dimension names so i actually think a
better name for that is level names but
i hadn't changed it yet and then this
has the column type saying how do you
know how do i interpret these columns
and you know ultimately that should just
be automatic or we could space specify
any column as automatic
these are faux columns right these are
columns after tabularization
is that correct right well the yeah the
columns the by the columns we're
referring to the last you know this last
this last dimension
okay so these are typically
i think it's easy to maybe there should
be name other than column but i think it
is like it's very easy to see what the
set of of you know values is that this
is referring to
that makes sense yeah it's not like it's
it's pulling them from five different
weird locations right it's it i mean
yeah yeah i mean you're right column is
maybe a little missy it should be you
know
last dimension vector types or something
but we need to come up with a good name
that's clear all right all right um
okay so parts so with the arrow link
functions they've implemented parts just
work very nicely why doesn't slice work
inside part that sequence that out is
really horrifying
well we had a
i think it was back in january
argument
yeah for the head but that's not what
the issue here
i think splice should just work inside
part one
i highly disagree because it's sort of i
mean the whole point of splice is it
only expands inside of lists but values
i mean that's that's the whole point
that's why sequence is is is difficult
okay fine okay yeah so it's it's it's
ugly but you you you at least know what
i mean i know
yeah so so we can do we can do parts
that the way the package the arrow
package is implemented we have to do we
can only do parts that are sort of
contiguous to each other um
and then so that's a limit on rectangle
so i can't do part
you know i can't do you know i can't
change this to like
uh
you know one comment i get it i get it i
get it
because they're not right they don't
there's only it's got to be spans
exactly but we can also filter and so
here i'm filtering by you know this
level name
you know greek
so that's the alpha so that's parts and
this is actual data so wait a second in
this arrow setup is this operating in
our standard memory space or is it a
separate process
uh it's a sep filter it's it's it's
loaded into our memory process isn't it
uh
yeah we are using our memory allocators
as
much as we can
by you know overwriting the the default
arrow allocator so
the theoretically yes okay but now in
our memory space
so yes yes okay so it's in our process
our memory space right right okay and
and i don't have i don't have the proper
byte count for this implemented but but
the arrow is quite efficient and
and i i haven't shown an example but you
can actually load a file and do the same
filtering thing you know from a loaded
file as well what what kind of loaded
file i mean csv file um
well let's see uh i mean
i mean general import should presumably
work or there should be a way of doing
this with import
here's here's a csv file okay that i
have how does this work i mean if it was
an hdf file for example could it work
do hdf files have have tabular data in
them
i don't know i think they have some i
mean i i don't know i'm just asking what
i think the h is potentially problematic
for us there because
okay h is for hierarchical so
um
yeah but but but so so some given
storage type like this arrow table
supports given
you know
this csv storage type so we can do a
direct in some cases we may have to do
if you want some particular storage type
you may have to go through
no i understand that's good iterations
you know we've got hundreds of formats
that we import
what you're saying is they're going to
be a small subset of those that are
usable directly as a file and a data
container
is that kind of i think at the first
stage that's got to be correct because
okay you know what what would you do
with like a png file or something no i
don't know i mean
if you look in our table i mean it's
fine there's certain data that we treat
as
if you look at the guide page for import
import types import formats there'll be
one you know there'll be a section
that's called tabular data and that's
probably what's already being supported
here anyway yeah that's that's what we
want to target i think yeah
i exciting but things like big json
files might be another thing that would
be relevant for instance
i mean basically this is json is
supported in arrow
okay fine not every flavor of it but but
at least
okay that's fine good i mean the real
question is just what what what has a
back end for arrow yeah right exactly
but i'm just trying to make sure
that we can define that that's fine it's
probably all the things people would
care about so that's a this is great
i think so actually one last one last
quick thing which is just that i was
noticing i mean the the hash greek thing
you have there where you're filtering
based on the uh you know the level
that's presumably a lot like the
supplied stuff that we were talking
about in the ild meetings
yeah and
i read my original case i had a way of
sort of automatically defining names for
dimensions and leonoid has a way of
making unique names for for for you know
different hierarchies which which you'll
see but yes i think it i think it
when when i was in that supply meeting
we were talking supplied i think this is
quite
i think we should think about both of
these at the same time
okay this is really nice stuff rob very
nice okay well well thanks and this is
um yeah so so so i think the big thing
the the big take out from this is we've
got this thing data container that we
can have different storage types for um
i think this is great i mean this looks
like it's well on the way that's because
we have a limited time let's see yeah
let's go to leonid
uh
all right so
uh
um
yeah so um i think uh my approach uh has
been pretty complimentary to robs
and there are many things where we have
some similar things going but
uh it's not really any kind of
duplication i i just want to show
um uh
the side of this that that i've been
concerned with was more about query
compilation
uh
so the goals here are listed here
basically
uh the the the problem
i was trying to address was uh much more
narrow in
scope in some sense but wider in some
other sense so i was specifically
focusing on data set
and
the goal was to see whether we can back
data set
by various 2d formats
and
also import certain existing two
deformants into data set and most
importantly run data set queries against
various backends
uh
okay so
uh here are the two types of workflows
that um
i was thinking about
one is if we have uh the data set
on the wolfram language side
and we want to somehow back it by flat
data maybe persisted somewhere and then
run some data set queries translated
into appropriate query language for
whatever backend the data now lives in
and then convert back for nested version
for just presentational purposes or
maybe for
some additional waffle language side
operations that are not supported by the
backend but are feasible on the already
computed data
and the second workflow is different at
least partly
and that there is already some existing
data somewhere in a relational database
or maybe
in some
barcad file or maybe somewhere else and
we also want to
be able to run data set queries to
basically represent that data in a
nested form
uh so
i want to show two examples and if we
want to go to a more conceptual level
how this flattening is happening and
what's the procedure i'm following i can
explain that as well
so one example is the
planet planets data set which
i'm not sure if it's
if it's large enough but i can change
the magnification effects that's fine
fine
okay so basically the only thing i did
to this documentation plan is data data
set is that i added mountains field for
the planets so
otherwise it's just this uh
documentation uh data set from dataset
documentation
and
the important object that i'm
introducing here which is a
which can be viewed as a generalization
of data dimensions introduced by rob is
what i call tableau dataset schema
which
i compute from this
data set
and which is effectively
containing
the bridge between the tableau data and
nested data so what's happening is that
every uh field in the nested
uh data set
corresponds to certain unique field that
is made up
for the um
you know the the final tableau data
tabler data the underlying table or data
that we want to
build from this
uh nested data set and so you can see uh
this is how uh this is how this uh
looks so
for
interestingly in this data set and this
is one of the reasons i picked it up was
that you have name collisions like for
instance the planets and the moons both
have masses and radiuses
but here because we are making up unique
fields the
end result the final tabular data set is
going to be
three of these
uh problems
uh of name collisions
now uh if we want to look at how this
pla planet's sample schema looks it's
actually
uh
the um
nested association
so uh i can execute this and
you can see it's something like this
uh what's important about this is that
this is
you can think of this thing as addressed
data set type
so it explicitly uses data set type
system
uh in that data set has certain
containers and atomic elements that it
deals with but it adds this
mapping to
a unique fields uh in a tabular data set
and together this is enough
to actually do
all the data set flattening or
unflattening that we we may want to do
and the other thing which is important
here is that uh the exact flattening and
unflattening procedure may depend
exactly on the
uh specific storage backend being used
and this uh schema by itself uh doesn't
say er it's abstract enough to be used
useful for any of those
uh specific
uh backends to which we want to flatten
uh the data set nested data or unflatten
uh so uh
here is one particular implementation
i'm currently using which is to flatten
to simply a list of associations
and this is what i call row based
tabular data set but it's just to
illustrate the principle in principle
we could have as many different backends
as we want and flattening procedures
adopted to those backends
so i'm creating this data set
and
it creates the schema and based on the
schema it creates a flattener
and then it creates the data we can
expand
uh and this shows you
the mapping between the actual keys in
this tabular data set
and the um
the appropriate keys in the nested data
set the fields and also this is how the
data looks unfortunately
it's a little bit
yeah but you get the idea so it's
completely flat
and it has this fields and values
uh but
it
was obtained directly from the
underlying nested data
and we can also look at this data
uh separately here
uh if we want to
now uh
there is a way to unflatten data
so there is also
if we call dataset internally it uses
the flat data and it converts it back to
the
nested form
and then
the thing that is most important this
approach and where i am
currently working on
is the queries and so far i don't have
that much to show
i have uh
the uh a part extraction
uh
and i can show how this works so
effectively this part extraction
actually works on
tabular data and then
is collected back into nested data at
the end
so
the resulting tabular data set
is now different if you look at its
schema
you can see that
it now is completely different because
it
basically some dimensions have been
eaten up by
extracting appropriate values here
some dimensions remained
and also
not all the
rows are present
so
you can see well actually here all rows
are present but
still it is a different structure
now here is another example where we are
extracting specific data for a specific
planet
and here uh
i'm illustrating some of the internals
so basically each transform has schema
transform and data transform
and in this case
uh the resulting schema is transformed
but also the data transform is
non-trivial because
even though here it is a part extraction
it is converted to selection problem in
the underlying tabular data and this is
similar to what rob was showing so
basically
what is generating generated here is a
select obviously this end is kind of
superfluous here so
it had to be optimized away but
so basically the part extraction in
general
is a combination of eating up certain
dimensions
uh and the selection problem
and here is the final example here where
i am actually asking for a single value
which is the
uh the mass
of the phobos moon of the mars and you
can see that it actually transforms into
uh schema tells you that there is now a
single value and the data transform
tells you what you have to actually
apply to the underlying tabular data to
actually get it
and it's generated by uh by this um
query compilation procedure now um
i'm currently working on the uh more
sophisticated sophisticated queries
and uh the obvious low hanging fruits
would have been
various forms of select
but i intentionally decided not to show
any of these today because uh what i'm
currently focusing on in that uh in that
part of my work is to be able to compile
a small subset of the core query
primitives of the data set which are
nested including mapping and including
some other things
internally used
and
i think i have now an understanding of
how to do that that mapping is rather
non-trivial but on the other hand if we
manage to do that then we will be able
to compile a large variety of nested
data set queries
into the queries against tabular data
sets
and in that capacity this this work i'm
i'm doing here will also be useful to
integrate with data container because it
will provide the
query compilation part for the whatever
api the data container and various
backends
attached today the container will
support
and so
hopefully this will be
the answer to the more sophisticated
querying capabilities to add those to
the data container part that rob is
developing and essentially uh in my
approach query
this query execution is a compilation
problem so
the ideal uh scenario is that
if we target the sql database then the
result of this data set queries will be
sql queries if we target data container
then the result of this uh data set
queries will be a set of a
certain sequence of api calls
for the api supported by data container
if we target arrow
through data container maybe
then again it will be a set of calls
passed through data container to arrow
to actually do the proper uh proper data
manipulation but for the user the user
will be able to use all that through the
uh
usual and
convenient and well known to the user
data set query language obviously not
the full query query language it will be
restricted to certain things that those
backends will support
but
we can think of thing of how to
reconcile that with the richness of data
set querying
a dataset could also
uh
have a part that will be later executed
on the resulting data
uh on the wall from language site and
that will make it possible to execute
things which will involve things like
histogram or bar chart or other things
which are explicitly uh you know
rendered and executed on the wall from
language side
now um
i may want
to show a little bit about the internals
just to explain
um we're going to run out of time here
so okay then then we can skip it uh let
me then just mention one more thing
and then i have some questions and
comments and things but go ahead go sure
i have another example which is kind of
sema
it's not automated yet but i was able to
use the part of this technology to
uh import a relational database as
nested data set
interval from language
uh uh and so uh basically the idea is
that
well i mean we start with certain
relation database i use the one that is
in the documentation for relational
databases
and then uh
i take part of it and define
the schema
it probably is too small to see but no
it's fine yeah okay
so this is the same tabular data set
scheme i introduced earlier
and by defining this schema
it shows how to basically translate
the
several tables
several relational tables in that
database into the nested uh data set yep
and then we can actually construct this
nested data set
using the unflattening procedure which
is part of this technology that
i've been describing i can just show you
it probably will look
pretty ugly but this is the
unflattener that has been automatically
generated from this spec
in the form of nested pure functions and
like all this kind of stuff
which actually acts on table or data and
results into this nested data set
and my point is being that the framework
i i prepared is is built in such a way
that
there is first abstract flattener
and then you can compile this abstract
and flattener into whatever actual
backend you want to use
so this is a very specific backend which
is just internal list of a socks but it
could very well be something very
different and we'll just need to compile
uh to a different backend to get this
unflattening procedure working for that
and then the goal is to run some queries
i'm not yet there but the typical i have
a few typical queries that we want to
run against this dataset
but uh
this
i think even even being able to import
relational databases as an in-memory
data set by itself is a valuable thing
and this part i already know how to do
uh so that's um cool so i mean but that
by the way i mean import should
presumably be able to support that in
the end
uh yeah probably yes as it can like with
the uh and from olden times it can you
know an access database or something you
can just import
but um yeah yeah but let's let's zoom
out for a second because we're going to
run out of time here and sure there were
seven minutes over time actually but but
um
uh
i mean so
the big picture here is
that you are creating
a
an api to take queries of the type that
are used in data set yeah and
both compile the query and compile and
re rearrange the data
so that that query can be run
on a
different backend from our standard you
know in memory system
exactly
okay
they could be run on data container and
whereas began supported by it it could
potentially be run in
sql databases and then
the underlying queries will be compiled
into sql queries
or it could be run on [ __ ] for instance
and then the underlying
data set queries will be compiled into
[ __ ] query language
yeah this is very cool so i mean look
the the the final vision is
it's data set whose first argument is
potentially some external reference
to
some other random database
but then you get to use the data set
query language yes and this takes care
of all of the translation
necessary to make that work yes and uh
to to commence on that first of all
obviously this query language will have
to be a restricted subset of the full
this data set query language available
in warframe language because of the
capabilities of those backends secondly
potentially we could envision uh the
kind of uh
fusion so that
once the backends do their work
essentially selecting and aggregating
and send back the data
we potentially could envision that the
remaining parts of the data set query
that exist on the query on a wall from
language side
will run uh on those on the on that risk
data that we receive so that the user
will be able to use
a richer set of data set capability i
understand so it's essentially a
callback it's a it's a
you know it's a delayed
sort of action i mean if you can
unthread the things that are not
runnable on a particular back end yes
and have them be presented in such a way
that they are then
you know
sent back to the wall from language side
to be run there
yeah then that should just work
exactly and so uh in the in uh one
other takeaway from here is that
essentially
uh our work with rob
is quite complementary in the sense that
um
we we have many similarities in our
approaches but
uh in my approach i don't even care
where is this data source because my
approach is basically a
compilation and so
uh hopefully in the ideal world we'll
have uh more sophisticated queries being
compiled through uh the machinery that i
presented and then used on
backends that are uh
that are basically supported in data
container
um so that's how that's how these two
things can be uh integrated at least
conceptually
but as far as the user is concerned
first question is where's the data
coming from so the data could be some
external thing that they never read into
memory that they it's just sitting there
it's some [ __ ] database it's some
sql it's a csv file whatever else it is
okay and they then reference that
through
essentially through data set
yeah
so
and then apply queries to it
getting the results go ahead yeah i i
see two scenarios here for for things
which are sufficiently external
uh going through data container might
not make sense and it makes sense to
just go directly through data set with
the first argument being the source just
as you mentioned
things that are sufficiently internal or
for which you know the synergy of using
data container is high it may make sense
to
register them under the data container
umbrella and then effectively
my part of this
thing will will will provide a query
translation or api call translation to
be used against the data container api
right so data container
is a much more internalized thing where
we're going to be
doing and you're saying what you're
doing here is much more
the actual
queries are going to be executed on an
engine that is not our engine yeah
not necessarily our engine may also be
our engine right but data container
it's
there are some semi externalized engines
like the arrow engine incorporated into
our engine but fundamentally the actual
computations are being done inside our
engine
whereas
your mechanism allows the possibility as
as for the
sql database stuff already built
to do
the operations in a different engine
potentially on different machines etc
etc etc
yeah and also for internal things like
data container for more sophisticated
queries
it will provide the same kind of
capability to translate these
sophisticated queries into the set of
data container api calls
i see so the data so the data container
api is another back end like sql
for
for your stuff and so then the then the
question is
uh
i mean so what's the relationship
between compilation technology for the
standard compiler
and this which is another compiler that
has different kind of data type concepts
or somewhat related but not quite the
same
uh i would say that um
the relationship is in the zeroth
approximation there is almost none
but if we decide to try
augmenting certain external backends
with the
for instance fall from language compile
functions
yeah or if we decide to use things
closer with data container in those
places the relationship will become more
important and uh at least through the
type systems they will be obviously
they have to be merged or maybe a
compiler type system will be used for
uh for this stuff but in some sense uh
this uh relationship is somewhat similar
to
how how the databases project uh
compiler to sql really is really relate
relates to
the uh of language compiler in the
zeroth approximation there is no
relation but as long as we want to allow
external databases
run some callbacks to the kernel for
instance which is uh well we can imagine
this might extend so once we reach that
point then they will become interacting
yeah and once we have just in time
compilation those call kernel callbacks
will probably be pretty efficient but
then the question is for these external
things i mean i would imagine if i'm not
wrong things like spark and so on do
allow you to send external code to be
executed on on separate database nodes
do they not
well i can't answer for spark but i can
answer that some number of relational
databases allow c-level callbacks
but i mean the question is can you push
a dynamic library for example to the
database server to be run on the
database server
um
i think you can do similar things for
postgres and for
i'm not sure
whether every every database supports
that but
many maybe most databases support so
that's a super interesting thing that we
could imagine and even in the most
sophisticated version i mean this would
solve another problem which is being
able to do distributed databases like
with you know spark or whatever the
latest thing is in that regard
um you know
with our standalone technology
um you could even imagine pushing a
complete wolfram engine
with some
compiled code that's being run so that
you could actually do arbitrary
uh queries
in the distributed right in the series
database
well the result there's there's a bit of
a problem in terms of permissions
on the other hand i'm pretty sure you
can do that with sqlite which sits on
your machine so and it has an external
function interface exactly
and this is something i also wanted to
mention there is sqlite and there is a
very modern even much faster
database uh actually a couple of them uh
which are free and uh open source as
well and can be used for like dagdb
which is a columnar version of sqlite
that's how they they position it
and also there is a tile db which is
arrayed based in process database
these are something like at least
for sqlite and duckdb these are file
based databases which could potentially
even be used in the cloud and with the
callbacks
uh we could create an incredible uh data
processing solution for you know
individual users who can just you know
use it that's very cool yeah we we are
deeply run out of time this is really
nice
the i mean
you know we we need to continue this
this series of meetings
um but uh uh if any if other people have
other comments they can give them but i
i need to disappear
um
anybody anybody have a quick thing to
say here i mean other than this is this
seems to be going really well
lots of work to be done it seems rob's
stuff is closer to being deliverable
than leonard's but um
the one the one comment i'd like to make
is that there's nothing there's nothing
particular in the data container as i've
set it up that requires it to be
you know in
in wolfram language process memory
okay it could be it's a reference
basically it could have any reference
you want
okay okay
very cool stuff
all right we should we should wrap up
here for now um
to be continuing another time